hello my people okay so I had a video
that was all set and ready to go for you
guys and hours before posting it I found
out that the information in that video
was just and I cannot post a
video with facts so I'm making
this video for you guys and if my voice
sounds a little weird this is post
tonsillectomy so bear with me I have
noticed a sweeping epidemic that's
infecting all most movies I'll give you
a hint to what it is yeah that's right
it's 3d otherwise known as the gimmick
that cost people three bucks more a
ticket now I do life 3d in some cases
some movies are actually enhanced by 3d
I've had to train your dragon' avatar up
Tron Legacy I think I hope but it was
just announced that The Last Airbender
is gonna be converted into 3d just like
a certain other movie was look if
anything came up collapse of the Titans
it's the revelation that the sudden
conversion from 2d to 3d only serves as
a gimmick that makes the movie look like
total it makes the people feel
ripped off I mean come on if they kept
Clash of the Titans 2d do you think
anyone would have complained about the
2d oh the 2d hurt my eyes no so just
don't meddle
just keep the last airbender 2d for
nothing else it'll look like you're not
cashing out on the whole 3d thing I mean
in 2009 there were like nine or 10
movies that were released in 3d in 2010
they're set to be twice as many there
will be virtually no time in 2010 where
a 3d movie isn't in theaters so the fact
is 3ds just not new anymore maybe fickle
to say so but it's just the way it is 3d
is not enough to get people to go see a
movie it will not help your cause to
turn a movie from 2d to 3d but you guys
just gotta get that three extra bucks
out of us don't you but to be clear I
don't have a problem with 3d as long as
it's not the thing that the studio is
apparently putting all their chips on I
mean if a movie's solid enjoyable you
know good and was planned to be in 3d
from the start than fine by all means
left a three-d role but I mean come on
when the movies made to B to D and then
3d becomes big and then the studio execs
have a powwow that looks something like
this
alright guys here it is so hear me out
after I took half our title so here's
what we're gonna do we're gonna take
their 3d technology that's right we're
gonna make our Last Airbender three
dimensions I said three dimensions
alright yeah let have't are stuck on
that one is we can call it Avatar The
Last Airbender put that up their noses
you talk like you from a 1933 radio
program oh you're gonna go there are you
then no Studios don't try to cash out on
the latest craze for the sake of trying
to help your movie become big just
release the movie you've set out to make
in the first place god forbid it's in 2d
I'll say it like this 3d in a movie is
like frosting on a cake or I've seen
depending on where you're from
apparently it's hard for me to say jeez
I sing I sing okay frosting can be a
sweet delicious bonus to the cake but if
the cake tastes like the frosting
is not gonna make it any better then if
you ever compensate and put too much
frosting on it after we eat it we just
feel sick and some cake doesn't need
frosting it's not meant to have frosting
it's fine without it
fact is preferred so don't frost your
cake just because other cakes have
frosting if a cake is good without it
then just leave it off otherwise you
might ruin it and I didn't realize that
movies and pastries had so much in
common
this just in movies can now give you
diabetes that is my take on the subject
and I am sticking to it and this
concludes the 10 day every other day
extravaganza of Awesome well technically
speaking it is on the 30th with my
nightmare and um straight review which I
am set to do because apparently I can do
it I did this so to all of you good
people who have watched the last 5
videos that I've done which one was your
favorite and why from the tongue to
lightest sucks video to this one comment
below which one was your favorite and
why let me know I love hearing from you
guys until next time peace